[Music]
katrina welcome
thanks for having me thank you for being
here where are we talking from
i am in my apartment in new york city
uh uh i call it upstate manhattan i'm
near the dw bridge
i have not been outside in eight days uh
i the last time i was out was to take
supplies to a friend who lives very
close by who is sick
technically since my show cancelled its
rehearsals i was supposed to be in
classic stage company's production of
assassins
uh we would have previewed on thursday
we would have started previews
um uh thursday the uh whatever the date
would have been the second
the first of april um anyway uh
i have not really been outside since we
canceled rehearsals so it's
it's been i'm taking it seriously they
say don't go out
so i'm not um well i'm very thankful
that some people are taking it seriously
unfortunately a lot of others are not
still which is just making it worse but
i can't help but
but ignore the fact that you're saying
that you're in your apartment yet i'm
staring at about 30
accordions right behind you yes there
are actually 34
in the apartment so that was a very good
guess you're you're only seeing a few of
them there's more on the floor behind me
there's some behind the computer uh
they're sort of strong
everywhere um yeah this is an instrument
that is
that has become very special to me and
uh
yeah to tell you a little bit about that
um i'd love that because i know
nothing about it except that it looks a
little bit like a mini piano
and i know that it's not so that's why
it definitely had
a great surge in popularity especially
as people were immigrating to the united
states
and they wanted to bring you know the
accordion is a portable piano
and it's a great way to bring a bit of
one's culture
so is it like fingering is a piano yeah
yeah it's the same over here there are
other
ones there's a gold one right here that
you can't quite see but it has buttons
so it's a little bit of a different
system but the piano is very
very popular uh it sort of lost a little
bit of its
its uh life uh when synthesizers made
an appearance because then that was
something else uh but now i i feel like
it's sort of having another moment
um when you've got people like weird al
who are incredible
accordionists who are doing yeah he's an
incredible accordionist uh but there
are it's still very very popular in many
different countries but i feel like it's
sort of having a resurgence here and
i know josh groban really helped that in
uh
with all his followers they were like
yeah the accordion is cool so
which i love that but um my grandmother
played accordion
yeah she toured singing gospel music
uh with her sister guitar so
the accordion was around it came out
occasionally
i i definitely didn't
quite have the same fondness then that i
do now for it but uh
when i booked my first broadway show uh
many years ago
i played uh a lot of instruments
and they asked me if i could cover the
accordion in the show
and i was like yeah i mean i play piano
i've played piano since i
could move and uh it was
when i picked it up i was like wow this
is such a great instrument why didn't i
take it seriously because this
this hand of this massive set of buttons
over here felt very
uh just daunting but then when i learned
what it was in a few
quick patterns i was like wow this is
amazing but i have to to say
that i was born into a family not just
my grandmother but my parents had a band
so i didn't have a choice when it came
to doing music
it was a requirement so drum lessons
piano lessons
and then uh we kind of worked out i
think i mean
yeah yeah yeah it's definitely it's
definitely worked out but uh
eventually when we had to choose an
instrument in school i
i wanted to play violin there wasn't a
string program so my mother took me to
hear an orchestra and a woman stood up
and played a note
and i didn't even care what the
instrument was i was like that one it
turns out it was the oboe which became
my major in college so
i went on to play all the wins some
brass some strings and but this this is
the one that that has
sort of just really i've latched on to
it before my my grandmother passed away
she had alzheimer's and dementia she
didn't really know a lot of
a lot of people and there was a real
defining moment where my dad
said hey you know why don't you come
home from new york and visit
and maybe play a little accordion for
grandma
and in the moment that i was there it
was the amount of clarity that she had
for
um everybody that's uh oh sorry there
must
did i lose you no okay if for some
reason
it um put you to the side of my screen
anyway um uh i had her for a moment
uh in the room and she asked if she
could have the instrument and play it
and
it was everybody was just like whoa and
i was like wow
uh this is something i need to take
seriously music is a key
it's it's it unlocks different doors in
our
in our our minds and our bodies it was
such a visceral reaction that she had to
hearing the instrument that
um and i don't know if anybody else was
maybe as aware i mean they'd all heard
grandma play the accordion so many times
but
i feel like for me it was like oh i need
to take this seriously
and then shortly thereafter i stumbled
into an accordion shop in new york
i wanted to buy a good one and i met
a man named walter kerr who became
a friend a mentor a band leader and i
play
uh he's since passed um
but he had the main squeeze orchestra
which is anywhere between 12 and 18
women and it's all accordion and we're
usually in
uh uniforms and and we play a multitude
of different styles
we've still kept it up uh but walter's
shop was called the main squeeze
main squeeze accordions and i have taken
it over so i'm
starting a business uh with uh his his
girlfriend's permission and i am
main squeeze accordions inc now and uh
yeah there's not there's not a shop in
manhattan
uh there are a few people in various
places uh in some of the other boroughs
um that do some repair work but there's
nobody in manhattan and i
love it so much that i have to do
first of all you know watching you i
watched you quite a few times in the
great comet
and so the the passion for for when
it's just unbelievable and i have to ask
because i still don't understand how how
it can be
that you play and you perform eight
shows a week
yes on the one of the most prestigious
stages in the world
and you can still come with the amount
of excitement and passion that you
personally come with
how does that even work tell me a little
bit about this experience of
performing and then performing with one
of your favorite instruments
yeah you know i mean what a gift
art is i mean look at look at what we're
going through right now
for anybody in the world that could
possibly suggest that we shouldn't have
funding for artists
everyone's at home right now everyone's
watching you know
netflix or or or watching their tv shows
or
you know hulu and those are all artists
and now i understand that andrew lloyd
webber is going to start streaming his
shows on friday nights like
there's like all of this art you can you
can take tours of museums
all of these art related things are
saying here
we will hold you during this time so i
feel like i've always
sort of felt that way about music in
general that it really
it it does something to us that lifts us
up
i volunteer for an organization called
artists driving to end poverty
and i've traveled to ecuador uh to work
with them for a few months and i've been
to india with them as well
uh to serve under uh i shouldn't say to
serve um
to work with perhaps underserved
communities
that's what i should say uh and they
believe that through the arts we can
empower
the minds of people to to help them just
navigate life in the most difficult
situations and so i'm so on board with
that so the idea
that i could ever take for granted doing
eight shows a week also i just would
like to
um say that i'm the only person that
didn't miss a show
you didn't miss a single show i didn't
want to ever not be there
wait how long were you there for how
long did it how long were you a part of
the
of the broadway cast i think we did 11
months
for 11 months you did eight shows a week
and you didn't miss a single show
well we would have opened we would have
started previews in november
so i mean essentially whatever the
length of the run was
i didn't miss a show and there was one
other person and the only reason he
missed a show was because he got swung
out to watch
to watch the show for a principal role
that he was covering but he and i are
the only ones that that were never not
in the building yeah i mean i
it was so important to me and anyone who
you know you would talk to from great
con will tell you that i i
really tried to take care of myself that
year it was important to me to do that i
mean
you know i i am a person who'll have a
glass of wine here or there but i didn't
that year i mean i literally i it was
about being as
getting i was also in school i was
finishing school at berkeley
at the same time so yes so schedule was
everything so um we closed great comet
and two weeks later i graduated from
berkeley which was insane
but uh berkeley and the other side of
the country
yeah yeah but yeah so i had a really a
really strong routine that involved
an exact amount of sleep exact amount of
study
and definitely eating right foods and
not putting myself
in a position where i would risk my
health to not do the show i want to do
the show you know so
yeah i mean i know a lot i'm honestly
i'm not that keen with with
the with the world but i know a lot of
people who go through the experience
of of being in broadway and the arts it
really takes
a tremendous toll on your body both
physically
being on stage and and running around
and dancing especially for a show
like great comet and whoever doesn't
know about it it's it's the it's not
just a regular show where you have a
stage
that's you know i don't know 15 meters
long
you're basically running around the
whole yeah the whole theater
i don't know it's like more than a
thousand seats and you're literally
running around and rattling everybody up
yes yeah so how is that
how was that whole experience oh my it's
you know i joined in the tent
yeah i joined in a smaller space and was
so
taken with the show and especially the
music
oh the music is just unbelievable
i mean to take 70 pages of a glorious
story and make that i mean that's just
gorgeous but yeah i will say i feel like
compared to some of the other people uh
in the cast perhaps i didn't have to do
as much running
because some of the some of the moments
that i had were
where actually i needed to be near your
brother or you know to hear or whatever
but um
i i don't know that i ran around as much
as maybe some other people which
probably helped protect what they kind
of had to be you kind of had to hold an
accordion for
oh yeah yes but also other instruments
right
i play a lot of instruments yeah i mean
but also in the show
uh no just accordion for that accordion
yeah just that in the tent i played
glockenspiel i think that's it but um
i know isn't that funny uh yeah but
and actually before the uh the assistant
musical director called me before we
started rehearsals and said
do you have a preference in accordion
and i said 100
this is what it has to weigh it has to
be
no more than this or else it will cause
problems for our backs and our bodies
and the
the other recordiness in the show i
think she was a little disappointed that
i chose a smaller model but i was like
trust
me you you will thank me later it is all
you need and
and uh she later of course she was like
yeah thank god that's all we had because
that was like
you know it was it was it was definitely
enough but
you know when you sit on stage
especially in that kind of
atmosphere you're we were very close to
people so i was
watching other people experience the art
in real time
yeah and there's something really
lovely about a shared experience that's
why i think
so many of us in new york are just well
it feels so weird that there's no
theater right now there's no music
there's that's why so many people are
doing these wonderful things online to
try to find
a find a voice to to use their art
because
shared experiences like that are really
really important and they even say
for for little kids that you know that
kind of
musical shared experiences is crucial
for their development you know
so totally yeah but so it was it's so
emotional i have to say that you know i
i saw the show
so many times and i got so emotional
every time and one of the most amazing
things that i haven't seen in any other
show is watching the cast
on stage you know there were actors that
were crying
every single show at the end yeah i mean
i
was one of those people i have to say
that
um there is a moment as the show as act
started uh where britain would sing
sonia alone
and uh it i didn't play in that song
but i played in the next song and i
wanted so desperately to be allowed to
stay on stage to watch her sing it every
night
that i convinced rachel chafkin that i
could wear the accordion as a backpack
and i was like no no i'll just come on
with it and then i'll have it and i just
will have it so i'm ready to go you just
put me anywhere and then i'll be ready
to play the next song
so i didn't leave the stage which meant
that i got to watch sonia alone
every night with your brother right in
front of me literally right in front of
me and then looking at britain it was
the best
gift of the year i mean just just
stunning so and and many of us were
pretty moved
every day by the show of course there
are moments where
you know your body doesn't feel as great
or something's happened outside of the
show
but the the thing with the theater is
the goal is to walk in and set that
aside because this is
this is a hopefully the art will tap
into a different part of your brain
and latch onto it and take you on this
ride that
takes away whatever else might be going
on you know in in your
in your life i know it was for me i'd be
like oh i don't have to think about that
project at berkeley because i'm going to
do a show
so you know it's it was very broadway
did you get nervous at all oh god yeah
and i swear it only gets worse what
specially auditioning
oh it's the worst i i'm i'm not i'm not
good at auditioning and
you know despite what my resume could
imply i
it is one of my least favorite things to
do it to
walk into a room and have to prove to
people that somehow i'm worthy of that
thing
piece of paper that i've handed them and
i hate it and
and often you know i majored in oboe and
like my fingers will shake before i go
to play the instrument that i
played so i will say
i mean i'm sure there are people that
have their method that have their
methods to
you know have their sort of anxiety
abated but
i don't use any methods except just to
try to breathe and go in there and smile
and
hopefully you know that it happens but i
do get nervous before shows
um because anything is possible you
can't you can't
shut down for a minute you have to be
present to all of it
anything can happen at any moment so
yeah you're not paying attention and you
trip with a
accordion on your front you fall like
that's not good so it's
you know it involved a huge amount of
paying attention
also we have a strobe light sequence
like
which honestly was one of my favorite
things to do of
all time it's incredible from the
audience it's incredible
yeah so how did you get to to broadway
because you know you're playing the
piano
since inception and then yeah yeah
during oboe which
is the most common uh correct
i don't know how many broadway actresses
and actors have majored in an
instrument in and well i i feel like
it's becoming more common to have people
who do
both but and especially it's been that
way in england for a long time they've
got a
an actor museum as they call them it's
there have been degrees
of people doing that and for quite some
time
um i also studied dance
and gymnastics and uh
earlier in my life i was i'd be more
likely to go to the dancer call
than the singer call so my first sum of
my first jobs are as a dancer
and uh i went on tour with
a national production of victor victoria
stone starring tony tenial
um of captain antonio fame the love will
keep us together that's captain antonio
i went on tour with uh her in a show
and uh somebody said oh hey there's this
some little broadway show not little but
uh where they need people who can play
instruments and that somebody was like
don't you want to play the oboe or
something and i was like yeah so on the
christmas break
in 1998 i
went home and made a cassette tape i
borrowed a flute from
my brother i brought my sister's
saxophone i brought a clarinet from
somebody that my parents knew at their
church
i brought my brother's trumpet and i
made a cassette tape
i think i put oboe on it i think i might
have i actually don't remember but um
and i sent it off to the roundabout
casting offices
and sure enough somebody opened that
thing i don't know if they ever listened
to it but they called me in
and i had six auditions and
eventually booked it coming back and
forth from new york while i was on tour
uh and yeah so i i booked my first
broadway show and it was
pretty young but the the skill of um
i was 22. wow yeah so the
the skill of playing instruments is is
not only do i love it it's just been the
best
gift and and often people have said oh
don't you just want to be an actor or a
singer and i'm like
no i love playing it's like it's an
extension of my
thought it's extension of my voice my my
body it's it's
i want i want to play and i i love it
i i know that i'm completely putting you
on the spot so feel free to decline is
there any way that i could get like a 20
second snippet
of how of how it sounds like
oh yeah um shoot let me find the closest
one
okay all right this is one that i bought
and
that i'm gonna sell i have to put you
down for a second to put it on i'll be
right back
all right
okay so this one was kind of an
experiment
um i've been going to italy and germany
to study accordion repair
and i'm i was just in italy
uh right before all this chaos happened
actually
and um i'm learning
different techniques in terms of the
repair so that i can offer more
services to people and one of those is a
lot of body repair
sorry if you're getting a lot of
extraneous noise my computer speakers
aren't afraid
anyway this is one that i've worked on
some tuning for
and uh okay that's undone let's see what
it was switching
can you hear it through my uh perfect
[Music]
all right let's see what's sitting
around here
[Music]
is it super loud for you no no it's
perfect
[Music]
i mean it's like it's so cool it is a
great instrument this is a smaller
one in terms of its settings but
it's got like someone should buy this
one i'm going to sell it for about 150
bucks if anybody wants to buy it
so uh but it's one of the ones i'm
repairing it's a shame that i don't have
a
a good one out and accessible for you
but um
you're not that is that is perfect and
honestly
whoever is interested needs to go to new
york and see and see a broadway show
that you're on that's
that's ah you're so sweet you're so
sweet but also uh you know if anybody
if anybody gets in touch with me i will
convince you somehow to want to play the
accordion so
i mean it's it's been a uh
a joy of mine to to try to get people
who have played piano to
take interest in this because it's
portable and it's it's great so i have
many of them that are uh in varying
degrees of repair here that i plan to
sell to people that i can get on board
with the squeeze box
wonderful katrina before we go i want
you to tell me
three words that you think describe you
best
oh um passionate
productive yes um
passionate productive
and it's like not just one word
full of gratitude what's how do you say
full of gratitude i'll take full of
gratitude as the third word
yeah yeah wonderful katrina thank you so
so much this is one
yeah i can't wait to check your series
and and uh
check out the other people i'm so
excited you said you're going to
interview a farmer and i all i want to
do is learn about plants right now so
that's like
that's super awesome yes thank you so
much and
and stay safe stay healthy thank you